une
prise
je tiens ma
vers le bas
introduction
le
dans
mon
Oh mon
corps
mon Dieu, j'ai été
présenter au
le
mon
nous
Oh
mon mon corps
vers le bas
introduction
jusqu'au
père
J'ai vécu avec toi, mon cœur était avec toi et tu as insisté sur le fait que tu étais à moi
Tu dis, oh fille du peuple, oh fille du peuple, oh fille
Tu manques aux gens et je t'adore, mon cœur est après toi et tu es devenu le mien
Tu disais, oh fille du peuple, oh fille du peuple, oh
Fille des gens, dis, dis
Dis ce que tu veux, dis-le, dis-le, dis-le, mon amour
Dis, dis, dis ce que tu veux, dis, dis, dis
Dis-toi
mon âge
Tu voulais ma mère, je ne voulais pas de toi, qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit ?
Tu m'aimais, tu m'aimais, tu m'aimais
Je ne voulais pas que tu te tues, tant que tu m'aimais
Tu m'aimais, tu m'aimais, dis, dis, dis ce que tu veux
Dis, dis, dis, dis
Ma vie, dis-moi, dis-moi ce que tu veux, dis-le
Dis, dis, oh
mon âge
Oh, tu le voulais, je ne t'ai pas trompé et je t'ai dit combien de temps ça avait pris
La situation est que tu m'as adoré, tu m'as adoré, tu m'as adoré, c'est ton droit
Tu te plains et tu ne comprends pas, je sais que je suis là avec toi
Raki pleure, elle pleure, elle pleure, dis, dis, dis
Tout ce que tu veux, dis-moi, dis-moi, dis-moi, mon amour
Oh, dis, dis, dis, si tu ne veux pas, dis, dis
Dis, dis, oh
Ma vie et mon cœur t'adorent, tu es ma famille tu étais
Tu dis, oh fille du peuple, oh fille du peuple, oh fille
Les gens t'aiment et mon cœur t'aime. Tu es ce que tu es devenu
Les gens, dites, dites, dites, dites ce que vous voulez, dites, dites
Dis, dis, ma vie, oh, dis, dis, dis
Je veux me dire, dis-moi, dis-moi
mon âge
une
Hé
nous
contour
prof fl
resp
tous
l'autre
couler
verser
nebr
h
salut ha l
nila ng
qqw je
qha l
Nela
guq nwa
Je qha l nela
kuqé
Iqi l nela ng
qqw
iih lela
Aqwan
iq l nela
otan
je
ngee
sem
même
ngw
ng
mer
nge
ngee
ngw
se
ng
Tangu
k
M
anul laa del
Mar la gu del
anul le del
del
Al
fl la
fl
le la
mille
je
unf
pour
les
dans
menue
allez je
du. du
ting
Cest ce qui est arrivé
en quelque sorte
espère tem b som de
Natureza tem tem magique
belle
onglet mélancolie et alegria
bm
parce que
n musique
Dalma Fito
c
musique toi
cing oi mar oi
mar tem
serenata
à côté de l'autre
nature
desde
mérinos susur
Baixinha
Caminho et falla para tudo
algorithme
C'est ça
vento.vento
musique
doit
feint
c na mano mano
manho
menu
n / A
min
sa.sa
som
mer
tr
Quoi
mo
du. du
Quoi
avec quoi
e ton
Guérissez-vous de la foi sans vos choix
C'est peut-être un petit Pink Floyd
Ces groupes sont liés à la langue anglaise
Cette plante est un animal de compagnie
Cette musique est la même que la musique
beau